-So, one of our writers, Karen
just turned 24 years old.
To give you an idea of
how young that is,
when Karen was still wearing
diapers to daycare,
I was wearing them on
"Weekend Update."
As a result,
she has a much different
frame of reference
than a lot of us here.
So we thought
we'd find out exactly
what Karen knows about the pas
in a segment called
"What Does Karen Know?"
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey.
-Hi.
-Hi, Karen. Welcome back.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-All right, so, here's how
this is going to work.
I'm going to show you
a photo of something,
and you're going to tell us what
it is or what you think it is.
And I should add,
you've not seen these, right
-Yeah, I've not seen them.
-Okay, all right.
Here we go.
Ready for the first one?
-Yeah!
-All right. There we go.
Karen, what is that?
-Oh, my God. An ancient iPad
Is it, like, an O.G. Game Boy?
-No.
-A pager but with a screen
-This is called a PalmPilot.
Does that mean anything to you
-Wait. Actually, yes, it does.
-Oh, great!
-I just had no
visual reference for it.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah.
-So you'd you only heard peopl
speak about it,
but you never cared to look at
what it would look like.
-Yeah. I sort of just, like,
closed my eyes.
I was bored by it.
-What do you think that
little guy is right there?
-I bet that's a stylus.
-Yeah, that is a stylus.
-Yeah!
-Good job.
All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Karen, who's this?
-Two twins.
An all-male reboot of
"The Parent Trap."
-No. They are brothers,
but they're not twins.
Do you really have
no idea who these are?
-No.
-Okay.
I'm going to tell you
their first names,
and you tell me
if that helps at all.
-Okay.
-Liam and Noel.
-Oh! Yes!
Liam and Noel Gallagher.
-Yeah.
-Oasis.
-And they're in a band. Oasis!
Well done.
Do you know --
Do you know any Oasis songs?
-Okay, I'm 90% sure they san
"Wonderwall"?
-Yeah!
-Okay.
-That's great.
And now a bonus question.
Based on this photo,
do you think they
like each other or don't?
-No?
-Yeah, that's good.
-Okay.
All my white friends love
"Wonderwall."
-Your white friends love
"Wonderwall"?
-Yeah.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah. I guess -- Sorry.
Yeah. Yeah.
-I just -- You know,
it hurts my feelings,
because I believe that
I'm one of your white friends,
and I like "Wonderwall."
-Yeah. But isn't that nice
I was thinking about you.
-It is nice that you were
thinking -- Okay.
-Yeah.
-Who or what is this?
-Just, I mean, a Teddy bear?
-Yeah, but this was,
like, a real
state-of-the-art Teddy bear.
-Oh, is it, like,
an off-brand Teddy bear?
-No. It's very on-brand.
-Oh, is it -- Does its eye
blink or something?
-No. His name was Teddy Ruxpin
and he talked.
-Oh, God. That's horrifying.
-Yeah.
But you have
to understand, like,
while you were growing up with
things like iPads, like,
this was a huge deal for us.
-Oh.
-Like, to have a talking bear,
that was just like hours.
It does now retroactively
seem terrifying.
-Yeah.
-All right.
We're going to stay with
siblings and hit you up again.
Who are these two gentlemen?
-Um...
Oh, God.
I actually -- I don't know
They're being served in court?
-Yeah.
They are being served in court
because they were
an Oasis cover band.
-Oh.
-And they did not --
-They didn't have the rights
-They did not have the legal
rights to the songs, yeah.
-That makes sense, yeah.
Okay.
-They wrote parody songs.
-Oh! Dang.
-I thought it was
easier than telling her.
Karen's very young,
and it would be very jarring
if she knew the truth.
-Dippin' Dots!
-Yeah!
Oh. No hesitat--
Have you eaten Dippin' Dots?
-Yes!
-Okay, great.
-Oh, my God. They're the best.
-Oh, that's great.
-That means -- That's nice tha
they've endured.
All right. Who's that?
-Just a cute dog?
-Yeah.
I'm gonna draw you to a detail
What would you say
that is there?
-A beer?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Does that mean anything -
help at all?
-I mean, I've had beer before.
-Karen, the question wasn't,
"Do you know --"
If we wanted -- Do you reall
think if we wanted to
show a card of beer,
we would have had it this smal
and had this much?
This was like, "Get a pictur
of a Budweiser,"
and they were like, "This is
the only one we could find."
So, this is a dog named
Spuds MacKenzie.
-Oh.
-And he was
the original party animal.
And it was at a time where w
all thought it was okay
to have things children like
sell us beer.
-Dang.
-Yeah, and so a lot of kids that
were well below the drinking age
would wear Spuds MacKenzie
like, T-shirts and stuff.
-Oh.
-Yeah, we wised up.
-You Budweis'ed up.
-We Budweis'ed up.
That's the sort of -- You know
that sort of
pun ability you have would
make you a big fan of
the Menendez brothers, who wrote
the parody songs for Oasis
-Okay. I believe you.
-All right.
You have some for me?
-Yes, I have things for you.
And you've not seen
these before.
-I have not seen these before.
-Great.
Okay, so, here's the first one
-Okay.
That is -- Well, those are
animated dinosaurs?
Dragons.
-Right. Yes, they are dragons.
-They're dragons and from
popular show called...
-Called?
-..."Dragon Time."
-Oh, my God! You're so close
It's "Dragon Tales."
-Oh, wow. All right.
-Yeah!
-Is that, like --
Was this, like,
a Saturday-morning
cartoon or an afternoon one?
-No, it was Monday through
Fridays, 4:30 on PBS.
-On PBS?
-Yeah.
-Oh, so it was,
like, a bad cartoon.
-No. Seth!
-I mean, not bad, but, you know,
you'd, like, learn stuff.
Do you know any of their
names if I asked you?
-Okay, so, that's Ord.
He's scared of a lot of things
This is Quetzal.
He's the teacher.
This is Cassie.
She's really nice and cool
That's Zak and Wheezie.
There are also two kids,
but they're not here.
But one of them is named Emmy,
and she says
"definitely!" a lot.
-Okay. Well, it's a shame sh
didn't make the photo.
-I know.
Okay.
-Well, that's just some sort
of skateboard.
-Yeah.
-Uh-huh.
-So, specifically,
it's called the Ripstik.
-Uh-huh.
-It's also known as
a wave board.
-Okay.
-And, basically,
it's like a skateboard
but much harder because
you have to, like,
move your hips,
and then both of these
go in different directions
and you go forward.
-Uh-huh.
-You look not cool,
but I felt very cool.
-You had one?
-Yeah.
-And were you good at it?
-I was really good at it.
-Gotcha. So, you'd, like,
basically come home,
you'd knock out an episode o
"Dragon Tales,"
and then jump on this bad bo
and just go rockin'
down the road.
-Uh-huh.
-Okay, great.
-It was really cool.
-I was drinking beers
with a dog.
-Okay.
-What?
Well, this looks like
some sort of ancient text.
-This is a -- Oh, my God.
Does anyone here
know what this is?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, this looks like...
well, like a Harry Potter --
-Yes!
-A Harry Potter --
like, one of their school --
a map of one of the schools?
-Yes!
-Really?
-Wow!
-Oh, my gosh.
It's called the Marauder's Map
-It's called the Marauder's Map?
-Yeah.
And, basically,
it was made by Harry's dad
and his three friends.
-Uh-huh. Okay, that's great.
Thanks, Karen.
This has been
"What Does Karen Know?"
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Give it up for Karen,
everybody.